ein echter riese und ich weiß genau wie
viel arbeit in ihm steckt ich bin hier
in dortmund und besucher den größten
weihnachtsbaum und bevor es losgeht gehe
ich noch mal rein
jetzt sind wir drin in meinem
meisterwerk naja also ehrlich gesagt ist
nur einer dieser tausenden von bäumen
meiner aber ich habe ihn vor wenigen
wochen höchst persönlich gefällt
aus diesem wald im sauerland stammen die
1700 rotfichten aus denen der dortmunder
risi gebaut wird eine soll von mir sein
viel holz und ich habe die qual der wahl
also brauche ich etwas beratern
warum wird für den dortmunder
weihnachtsmorgen gerade die rotfichte
genommen ja weil die rotfichte
sicherlich kostengünstiger ist wie eine
eine nordmanntanne und ich sag mal
dieser baum wie gesagt schließt sich
eben sehr gut an das stahlgerüst in
dortmund eben an die fichten für den
dortmunder weihnachtsbaum sind zwischen
dreieinhalb und fünf meter hoch
aus sicherheitsgründen darf ich meinen
baum nicht mit einer motorsäge sondern
nur mit der handsäge fällen
[Musik]
geschafft dieser baum wird ganz groß
rauskommen
in dortmund zusammen mit den anderen
fichten die gut verpackt im großen lkw
noch vor sonnenaufgang angeliefert
werden
weihnachts romantik kommt hier noch
nicht auf
[Musik]
die erste lieferung ist schon vor ein
paar tagen an das 45 meter hohe gerüst
montiert worden
jeder baum wird vorher in form
geschnitten gestutzt und zur befestigung
mit schellen versehen
manche arbeiten hier schon seit 22
jahren mit
wie sieht denn der weihnachtsbaum zu
hause bei ihnen aus ja ich habe diese
wenn ich ehrlich bin ich habe die ersten
jahre erstmal kein baum mehr sehen
können und ich hier weg gehabt
denn nicht nur fichten stecken in diesem
riesigen baum auch bis zu 1500
arbeitsstunden die man von außen gar
nicht sieht aber hoch oben auf dem
stahlgerüst
[Musik]
höhenangst hat hier offenbar niemand
aber ich habe ziemlich weiche knie und
so ganz sicher fühle ich mich auch nicht
aber der ausblick ist sensationell
eine ladung fichten wird nach oben
geliefert darunter auch meine selbst
gefällte rotfichte
ich glaube hängt aber irgendwann löst
sie sich und dann gehts ran ans gerüst
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich stolz darauf sein dass
mein baum auch teil des weltgrössten bei
uns ist
[Musik]
insgesamt vier wochen hat die gerüste
firma zeit um den baum vollständig
wachsen zu lassen
die dortmunder weihnachtsstadt drumherum
wird erst ganz zum schluss aufgebaut
[Musik]
40 tage lang können sich die besucher
dann an mehr als 300 ständen mit
weihnachtsgeschenken und spezialitäten
versorgen
der absolute höhepunkt aber das ist der
moment in dem der riesige baum
beleuchtet wird
darauf warten hier alle
[Applaus]
es war echt beeindruckend zu sehen wie
dieser baum entstanden ist wie tausende
von fichten zusammengebaut wurden
tausende lichter schmücken
und jetzt kann man nur noch sagen
[Musik]